now one of britain's best known
designers is in glasgow today showing
delegates at cop26 how fashion can help
fight climate change stella mccartney
has teamed up with prince charles to
show how the next generation of
sustainable clothing might well look and
i'm very pleased to say stella joins us
now very good morning stella
morning
and you are at one of my favorite places
in glasgow kelvin grove just explain
exactly what the installation you've put
in there today is hoping to achieve what
does it say
well i agree it's beautiful here um
really i'm here to represent the fashion
industry
at cop 26 one of the most harmful
industries sadly in the world to the
environment so today i'm opening up an
installation talking about the future of
fashion and providing some solutions
hopefully to a better way of business
i i detected this light side there it's
the solutions that that everyone needs
and as you mentioned i mean the fashion
industry itself has over the years
not covered itself in glory so to
explain exactly how we can perhaps try
and put this industry onto a rather more
sustainable footing
well today i've got um i'm showcasing a
lot of the technologies that we use at
stella mccartney for example a couple of
weeks ago in paris i um
showcased the first ever mushroom
leather mycelium bag and put it on my
runway so we have the mycelium here you
can see there's a ton of mushrooms
behind me and it's just showcasing these
technologies that really can be the
future of fashion swapping out for
animal products which account for so
much deforestation every single second
um a hundred football pitchers are cut
down
every you know in the rain forest so you
know we have to stop the animal
agriculture side so we're looking at
those solutions here we're also
showcasing the first ever vegan football
boot that we did with paul pogba
we're looking at some regenerative
cotton farming projects that we're
working on in turkey
and we have a huge amount of technology
where we're looking at completely
recycled materials as well so it's
exciting we have some really really
positive solutions and i think that it
will really lessen our impact in a
negative way
absolutely fantastic and incredibly
exciting but i have to ask you to hit
the rewind button and explain exactly
what mushroom leather is
it's the mycelium root system of
mushrooms which basically connects all
of us on the planet and mushrooms are
neither animal nor vegetables so they're
kind of funky and crazy but they
basically are grown in a lab it uses an
extraordinary amount less of energy and
water
it's a really really clean way of
producing a kind of leather alternative
whereas um leather is basically
accounting for 18 of all of the
greenhouse gases right now for fashion
alone so
it's it's really unsustainable when you
look at leather i'm also launching a
policy here today to try and encourage
people to stop using leather and fur and
skins and feathers um in the world of
fashion and so yeah the mushroom
leathers is a great alternative
it sounds fantastic but seller i have to
ask you know why has it proved so
difficult for the fashion industry to to
put its house in order i mean in so many
other ways fashion always tries to be
ahead of the curve to be actively
involved in whatever the zeitgeist is
and is and greenlight shoes clearly have
been for some time
yeah i couldn't agree more i mean we
could we're probably the most
unfashionable industry and the most
behind industry really which is shocking
i'm excited though here at cop26 it
feels like we're really on trend you
know this is the most exciting and in
fashion conversation to be having thank
god and it's the most important as we
know for the future of our planet um our
industry has taken too long i think
you know primarily because we have no
policies in place we're not regulated in
any way and i'm really pleasing with the
politicians here to give us some
guidelines like they do the automobile
industry you know there's hard-hitting
targets to get clean
there's incentives there's actually you
know you're penalized i'm so sorry you
have to pay the price financially
yeah still i'm so sorry we have to let
you go because we're just about to go
off here but i won't let you go by
without saying you need to see the
salvador dali upstairs it's fantastic
still mccartney thanks for being with us
absolutely i will